everybody welcome to live coding with
Jesse and I'm Jesse and we're gonna do
some coding today pretty much right
where we left off yesterday I've been
trying to figure out how to get rid of
these errors that we were having so just
to do a recap for for what happened
yesterday if you missed it
we are trying to use the materialized
CSS framework in an old website that has
a lot of stuff going on a lot of
different files put in by different
companies and different developers and
there's pretty much no documentation and
so we're just learning as we go and when
we tried to implement the side nav from
materialized we kept getting an error so
I tried commenting out different things
so it really doesn't matter if I comment
out the side nav function the modal
throws an error and so pretty much
everything that I'm trying to do from
materialized doesn't work so I'm just
going through and trying to remove
everything I can that may be causing
conflicts and hopefully hopefully
something will work out so that's where
I'm at
just to show you see a lot of stuff on
the screen right now so let me pull over
here's what we have right now right so
this is not this doesn't look good at
all right here's the live site that
we're trying to change and
and this is we're gonna try to change it
to well at least in terms of the header
it'll definitely be a different
background image this is just a stock
photo but we want the header to look
like that in the side and I have to look
kind of like this we're gonna switch in
that new logo that we used for the the
last project for project 2 but other
than that everything should be the same
so we're here right now but once we get
with the exception of some weird padding
issues that I'll have to deal with once
we get the the functions that come built
in with materialized to work this should
look a lot better so let's let's tell
you what let me move this over for now
and let's give it a refresh because I
just did a few things before I started
the stream and I haven't checked it yet
all right so hey check this out so not
not perfect but look at that
we got we got it working so that's good
news
so at least some of what we're doing is
working let's let's check out let's
check out the console let's see Wow no
errors awesome I mean other than this I
I realized that that's just not gonna
find that image but that's that's great
alright so here's what I commented out I
commented out this custom das file
because I was I was looking through it
and it really didn't have a lot that
that I thought we needed so let me I
guess it's not going to be in there
anyway to get out but the it was
basically doing a lot of things for
components that I'm that I took out that
aren't even on the page anymore so I
think it should be fine maybe later on I
should go through and look at it a
little bit more closely just to make
sure nothing was really necessary but
there must have been something in there
that was messing things up the only
other thing I changed is I took out this
version of jQuery which I thought I had
already done but I guess I either didn't
do it or I undid it somehow and didn't
realize it so now we are using I think
we're still loading two different
versions of jQuery so we have this newer
version for now I'm okay with that at
some point we're gonna have to decide
whether we want to run the older version
or the newer version and how we're gonna
do that we'll see what the best way to
do that is let me say I had everyone in
the live chat oh we got a question
already so Jay rec says hey Jesse what
programming language did you learn first
back-end
[Music]
I want to say the first language that I
feel like I really learned to the point
where I could I could build stuff that
works was JavaScript and that obviously
is back in with node and front-end if if
you want to if you want to take learn
and the really loose sense then I'd say
C++ I did build a calculator in C++
before I learned how to do anything in
JavaScript so but I don't other than
like just the basic concept programming
concepts that I learned when I took a
class on C++ I don't remember much about
it like syntax and things like that I
haven't even looked at any C++ code
probably since I took that course but it
was cool because I just I remember
learning things like different types of
loops for loops while loops learning
just a lot of the basic stuff so anyway
I don't really use other languages that
much I mean right now it's like some
c-sharp stuff but am PHP I guess I I
guess I have done some PHP with
WordPress so I completely forgot about
that but yeah I can I can do some PHP
I've done like file upload like file
handlers you know a handle form data and
upload files with PHP so I guess I I
could include that in as well I once
took a little course on Java now that I
think about it
we built a game in the class but it was
more like just a demo like we
collaboratively built the game so the
teacher did most of the work
hey everybody
okay so egos asking me about the the
hack right so let me explain this so I
was just I was just talking about these
two different versions of JavaScript so
you can't see the other one but it gets
input basically through this tag here
but it's an old version I think it's
like one point ten or something
so we I want to use the newer version
but the problem is I can't find where
this data is getting pulled in to change
that so evo had a great idea was well
why not just find where it's at you know
in the file structure and then just take
this file and rename it and I thought
that was a really great idea until
earlier today I was gonna do it and then
I realized that if I did that it would
change the version of jQuery on the live
site and I don't want to do that because
in the off chance that it does cause
some weird problem I may not even know
it because there's just way too many
pages on the site for me to go through
and check that and I wouldn't want to go
through all those pages on the site it's
just too slow it would take me all like
days so anyway I'm not gonna do it right
now
I actually really want to know where
this is coming from anyway because it's
loading a lot of other files so we may
not even need those files so that was a
really good idea if this was really an
actual test server instead of some weird
I don't I don't even know it's it's
supposed to be a test but everything I
change changes the live site if I'm not
careful okay
hey Sebastian's back awesome so
Sebastian was a regular here on this
livestream in the chat but he recently
went to Germany and says just got
Internet awesome okay let's get started
if you haven't if you haven't watched
before the format is basically I do
twenty five minutes of code five minutes
a question to answer another 25-minute
session of code and then the end I do
Question and Answer
occasionally I'll do more code I'll go
longer but today I'm just going to do
the two sessions of code two sessions of
questions and answers so that's what
we're gonna do now
and I'm gonna set a timer to help me
stay on track if I can find it and I
think I'm also gonna clean up these
windows a bit so once I once you start
working on more than one project things
start to get a little bit crazy so I
still have everything open from project
2 which is not done yet and now this
this project I have lots of stuff open
for I was working on another project
earlier as well and so I have a lot
going on I actually spent most of the
morning going over a site it's AG it's
only like a few pages but it's like a
little site that we have this other
company building for our single sign-on
system and it's just really disappointed
I just told them some basic things to do
so it matches the style that we use on
the other site just I mean really basic
like literally I gave them the CSS and
said here put this in and then I checked
they came back and said hey we've done
like everything that you asked for
except for this one thing I checked and
they like didn't even get 50% of it done
so really disappointed and
I mean this was like really basic stuff
and they they couldn't even get a hover
to work like a CSS hover it was yeah it
was just odd I don't know how much we're
paying them but I don't think I want to
know I think it just made me sad so
anyway I had to go through and basically
in dev tools figure out to write all the
code out and tell them exactly what line
to replace so that this gets done I have
until the end of October it's supposed
to launch at the end of October so I
just I mean it's not my project I'm not
really gonna get credit for it but I
still don't want it to look bad because
it's you know it's gonna reflect the
university so anyway sorry for the
complaints I don't it's just I just want
to find a really good like outside
company that does quality work and and
can understand like that things need to
be precise so you can't you can't just
get it like close enough especially when
I'm giving very precise like I'm giving
them the CSS I'm not just saying oh you
know make it look pretty which is vague
I'm actually saying like this is exactly
what I want and anyway we've had some
bad luck with different companies and
websites just really really helped me
find somebody good that we could stick
with when we need to outsource projects
okay sorry I said I was sorry for
complaining and then I just went on
again from the minute let's I was just
cleaning up Windows so let's get the
windows that you know the desktops that
we're actually gonna use the most we'll
get those right next to each other and
so here we go get this one just one I
think that's I think that's it
so we'll have our code oops maybe I
didn't do it right
oh no it's it's right code here right
here okay all right so here's what we
have right now not terrible but it looks
like we still have a lot of weird stuff
going on with CSS so this should be up
at the top I mean this should not be all
moved over so we're gonna have to just
go through and inspect these elements
and see what in the CSS is causing it to
shift around and then as a last resort
we can use important on our CSS
properties but a better way would be
just to make our selectors more specific
than what's currently in place I think
that'll be that'll be the best way to do
it I don't want to get into actually
changing the CSS that's already there
because for every file I'll have to make
a test file and then I'll have to change
the names right of when we're importing
that and then I'll have to work on that
CSS and hope that it doesn't mess
something up elsewhere I won't really be
able to test that at all so you can see
it would be kind of a mess so and in
this instance I'm gonna be very specific
with my selectors so that I know it's
only going to affect the stuff that
we're putting in so we we may have to
throw in some IDs and things and use
that which I normally wouldn't do but in
this case we want to make sure it
doesn't cause side effects in other
places okay so let's just let's start
checking these things out and we'll try
to make some space
and let's get rid of this we don't need
that right now just make as much space
as we can here all right this looks good
interesting
yeah that is that's very interesting
okay let's just check out what's going
on oh I thought that the the one that I
had oh well
so now let's let's get this let's move
this over now oh I know this is the
right one I don't know what that's to
you guys just get rid of it oh that's
the project - okay whoops I don't need
this right now let's move it over
man I have so as you a lot of you
already know I listen to music in my
headphones while I'm doing this and a
country song just came on and I like
pretty much all music but I'm really not
a big fan of country music man how did
that how did that come on
but anyway pretty distracting just for a
minute here but let's check out let's
check out what's going on so here's our
our nav rapper and
let's check out our header first is
that's the outside the outermost
container so you can see that's down a
bit and let's see where so this is our
file so anything in new design we want
to see that at the top and we don't want
to see anything crossed out because
that's our CSS also anything that's
materialized mndot CSS we want to see
that actually applied if we see anything
crossed out on those two then we'll know
that that's being overridden by
something else so so far so good on the
header but it looks like we have some
weird stuff going on here right this is
from styles dot CSS which I did not
write so there we go let's check it out
let's make it alright so it didn't fix
it totally but it got rid of that thing
at the top right so you can see we had a
position:absolute and we had top twenty
right that was because right you can see
in the version site we have now that it
actually does have this little gap at
the top so that's where we got that from
so now we don't have that anymore
let's see okay with a hundred percent it
that that really shouldn't be a problem
we could probably just leave that in
there we don't need that top anymore
so what we need to do though is
we need to figure out what type of
positioning we wanted to have and I
think we're gonna go with a fixed with a
fixed header let me double check yeah we
wanted what this navbar to be fixed
actually that's interesting that
that's really odd that the navbar fixed
position is not fixed
okay so I guess the interior positioning
is fixed we just can't tell you can't
scroll right now let's see if I can make
it scroll okay so that positioning is
working so we're good with that all
right so we still need to figure out you
know this big gap on the side and I
think I was thinking about this I think
to some point last night and I was
thinking you know when you use
materialized there's a structure to the
page that we just don't have here right
we have all this other stuff going on so
I think we need to check out what's
outside of this header and just see how
things are lining up and see how much of
this structure we can actually change
without messing things up so that's
where we'll look we should probably
remember what we did with this header so
position we don't want absolutely we
don't once house let's just say sorry
position okay so static so let's go with
static and okay top let's double check
new design 32
oops all right so let's go to our new
design whoops this is uh Jas we need our
CSS you designed that CSS I'm go to 1:30
there we go okay so we need position
static and top auto now it should
override right because it's just it's
the same right it's header here header
here and we're loading this after so the
cascading nature of
skating stylesheets should take effect
and what we have will override what's
there so let's refresh just to
double-check yep and there we go so all
right so there's one salt you can see
how tedious this process is gonna be we
may we may end up only getting a new
header we'll see I hope to do like an
entirely new homepage but that if it
keeps going at this pace then it's gonna
be tough
hopefully as we go along we'll we'll
have less
you know maybe we'll figure out a lot of
what's what's going on and what's
causing this and it won't be as big of a
deal okay actually I just thought to
check to make sure that this this is
working and it is now if you remember we
we have not actually added these the way
we want to yeah well sorry
I really haven't gone all day and now
I'm yawning during the stream so I'm
gonna drink some some G fuel
if you're not familiar with G fuel it's
like a five-hour energy except it's
powder and you mix it with water just a
lot of vitamins and caffeine okay so we
still need right these are all
hard-coded right now so that's not what
we want so we still need to add put that
in but before we couldn't even see this
to tell if what we were doing was
working so we're gonna do that since
we're already kind of into the CSS let's
do a little bit more of this and get it
to the point where it looks about like
it should and then we'll just try to put
in some of that stuff from the template
that'll give us these links I'd like it
if we could get the links just like this
but as long as we can get close to that
I'll be happy with that too I'm kind of
hoping that we can reevaluate some of
these links when we redo this but we'll
see evidently when before I was here
when this site underwent a redesign the
last time figuring out what links get in
the top navigation on the homepage was a
huge deal like every department one of
their stuff on the front and so don't
really want to go into that again if we
don't have to but I think it could use a
bit of cleaning up all right so let's
check out if we're doing yours so we
have this inner page outer see that this
may be messing us up a bit it's C I may
have to just put this on the other
screen for a second just so I can see
okay all right check this out you see
that so we've got we've got some weird
margins going on here
I'm guessing yep there it is okay so I
was guessing there is a max width on
this and there it is there's a max width
and it's set to zero Auto
so anything in there can't go past there
so that's why we're cut off at least on
this side
some reason we're overflowing here on
the other side which is good shoot I
click the link okay we're back
so let's mess around with this a bit max
with there we go
awesome alright so check that out look
it works let's make sure this works cool
oh man why is it always so I don't know
what's over there that I keep clicking
but alright so that works so here's what
we're gonna do we what's above this okay
so let's check what we're doing to
materialize right now because this could
take that I think in materialize the way
you structure it is there's a main
component I can't remember if header is
supposed to be inside of main or not and
so let me double check that and then
that'll determine what I want to do with
this div so I think I have it
I guess it's this way here we go so
let's see what how we structured it here
okay so here's our header and there's
main below it and then it's just bought
ietter mein okay I think we're gonna try
to completely get rid of this inner page
out of wrap or a page outline thing okay
I imagine it might mess some other
things up but we'll see so what I want
to do is get rid of this completely so
that our header well we have two options
either we can try to move the header up
so it's outside of this and then make
this our main so try to basically just
add the class main to this and see if we
can override the other styles or get rid
of it completely and you know put in a
main down here so we'll see what's
easier once we check this out so let's
go back to our be our main main test
master so let's try to find that what
was that called inner page see if we can
find it here in their page there we go
okay awesome so it looks like we could
yeah we could just move this up I'm
guessing that everything that I do needs
to be inside this form so I'm gonna put
it inside the form for now I'm not sure
Umberto's not in the live chat and he's
he's good with c-sharp but if anybody
knows I think when we're doing stuff
with like dotnet everything's got to be
inside this form so that's what I'm
gonna do it like that for now and I
think it should work and I'm gonna the
indentation in this file is just
ridiculous I don't know how this
happened but it was like that before we
started also I still haven't all right
let's save that but then let's
let's get the important stuff out of the
way first we have got to change these
settings so that it uses spaces instead
of tabs so let's see there we go
tab size needs to be equal to 2 oops
[Music]
the editing in Visual Studio code is
actually pretty cool all the way copy
the settings sure so just kind of as an
aside here if you never done editing and
visual studio code it's kind of cool I
like it
so you have your settings JSON and here
on on this panel they give you all the
settings and you can search them and it
gives you a description then you can
click over here to edit and it copies it
over to kind of like your settings file
that just overrides all the other stuff
right so this is where you put you know
your custom settings and so it's pretty
cool like you'd see like I am what did I
do I put in here I changed something in
my user settings and I can't find it but
anyway it's somewhere in my settings I
took away the the map like the mini-map
thing that was on the sides it was taken
away too much space but it's really cool
pretty much anything in the UI you can
change from there so all right so let's
test this out maybe it didn't work it
does not look like it worked
no all right maybe I need to restart for
it to take effect we'll see I'm gonna
just double check that it actually yeah
it's in there
the settings overridden based on the
file contents when editor detected
annotation okay so since that file
already has that kind of indentation
that's why it's doing that so I'm gonna
leave that alone we're just going to be
stuck with that but going forward for
new files we have in Visual Studio code
will have the same indentation that I'm
used to using alright so now that we've
we've changed this let's see what things
look like
all right great let's make sure oh nice
and look at that before I don't know if
you remember but the overlay was coming
over top of this and now it's not so
that's that's awesome
at least at some point it was coming
over top of it great and there it is
there's that that link so I'm getting
I'm gonna have to fix that something's
that's not how it's supposed to work so
that's that's a minor thing I'll just
fix that later but anyway double check
okay great that's working so when you
click on one over here it opens a side
bar and it automatically opens up that
all these sub links wonderful great
alright instead of some weird stuff like
the color of links is when you hover
changes to blue we don't want that but
not bad so here's the next step let's
try to populate the links in the side
nav from the link the data that we're
getting from from our content management
system and we need the we need to put in
the logo too so we'll figure out where
to where to bring that logo in at and
[Music]
actually I think we're using an SVG logo
it's a pretty long SVG but we can
potentially just copy and paste the SVG
stuff right in there we'll see I might
do that okay so for now we need to go to
our
I'm main nav test I just we need to look
at what's going on here and figure out
where to put these so
okay I'm still somewhat familiar with
what the mark-up looks like on the the
main site so this section I guess I'll
show you all what it what it looks like
so it was just make a lot of sense if we
just take a look for a second so we have
these these links here then we have this
menu here down here these are the the
bottom links that they're talking about
so for each one of these we need to get
all of these sub links and then the
bottom links as well and put them in
that side nav under there
so this is where keep on the wrong way
so this is where we're getting this
bottom links so in this green box menu
hey at least the ternary operator is the
same as it is in JavaScript let's see
that's good I understand something so if
you're not familiar with the ternary
this is basically like an if statement
so it's if this is true then do this
which in this case is put in this little
bit of markup if it's not true then do
this
okay
so you might be able to copy this
actually my the timer went up so before
I get into this let's do the five minute
five minutes a question answer and then
we'll get back and we'll start copying
some of these and putting them up in our
code up here and seeing if we can get
this if we can get it working okay
let me find my timer there we go
do our short break all right I'm gonna
scroll up I'm probably not gonna get
through everything in this five minutes
but if I don't get to your question now
I'll get to it at the end of the stream
you know like there's a lot of talking
going on a lot of chat but not a lot of
questions
okay here's a question
rich rich Bob says is Ubuntu better than
Windows and I would say it just kind of
depends on what your preferences are I
mean you could probably match them up
like head-to-head on certain things and
say you know one's better than the other
at certain things but I I really only
use Linux for servers and not as I mean
if we're comparing servers I definitely
prefer Linux servers like an abuti
server over a Windows server but I don't
have enough experience with linux
desktops to be able to really say one
way or another evo says I find it it is
harder with Linux because you need to
have a pretty deep understanding of all
your your tools on Windows it's pretty
much all done for you okay
yeah that makes sense from what I've
heard from people who do use Linux for
desktop it's like if if you like
handling a lot of that stuff then it's
really good but if you just want
something you can just turn on and it'll
work and and you don't have to worry
about it then windows might be the way
to go although if you want something
that just turns on it just works a Mac
is probably the way to go I've never had
other than a Chromebook I've never had
something that just starts up so fast
and is reliable
there's definitely drawbacks as well
like how much it costs but and the lack
of being able to customize things but
it's definitely reliable
okay
all right so you have let me see some
questions so sy asks does he look at the
chat and I think someone else already
answered but I'll just reiterate that
that yeah I do look at the chat so at
the beginning of the stream I spend most
of the time coding I will take a break
halfway through and answer questions and
then at the end of the stream we'll get
to all the questions so and then
occasionally I do look over when I'm
coding it just so happened that this
coding session this first one I I didn't
really look over very often
Jordan asks what we're building
basically we're not really like building
anything we're just kind of trying to
improve an existing website so it's an
older website it's built on some older
technology we're trying to go in going
in there and we're giving it a facelift
and trying to make it a little bit
faster so we're gonna add some material
design style UI and try to just get rid
of as much as much code as we can that's
unnecessary there's a lot of files being
loaded there's a lot of images being
loaded we want to just clean up that UI
get rid of a lot of it and just do what
we can I mean this site's probably a
year or so away from being totally
redone anyway so we just need to keep it
going
and and make it look a little bit better
and until till we can get to the point
where we're gonna redo it totally Daniel
asks is there any way we can help you
out
[Music]
I said Daniel I don't I don't know if
you were referring to helping me out or
helping someone out in the chat but if
anybody right now this project is kind
of hard to collaborate on because I
don't have a whole lot on github right
now like I have this on github and I
have a I think I have this linked in the
description the fu s starter template
that's on github and it has things like
in this menu but I'm working on getting
some version of of this and github I
just what I want to make sure that I
leave out any of the config files and
because that has like database passwords
and usernames and things in there so I
want to just be really careful about
making sure I don't put anything that I
shouldn't I don't get hope so when I get
a chance I'm gonna put some of this out
here and then at least you'll have a
chance to check it out will you be able
to run it probably not because you'll
need you'll need Ektron which nobody has
Ektron it cost a lot of money and
there's like no one in my mind there's
no reason for anyone to use a cron
anymore it's it's not a great system
compared to what we have now who knows
maybe well at one point in the past it
was a really awesome system but now it's
it's definitely shows its age so alright
so I got through I don't know about 3/4
of what's in the live chat so I'm gonna
go back and do a little bit more coding
another 25-minute session and then I'll
go through everything in the live chat
so I'm gonna write down where I stopped
so I don't doesn't take me forever to
find it
okay there was some talk about whether I
respond to comments and slack or in a
live chat I do check in on the slack
Channel when I can but that's I usually
don't check slack during the stream so
that's all you know if you want to send
a message or something when I'm not
streaming slacks the way to go if I am
streaming go ahead and put it in the
live chat and I'll check that the same
goes for anything else so Twitter or any
social media channels I - I know almost
never check that while I'm streaming but
I I do try to get to it after before and
after Xtreme it was just odd
somebody from business services
department here just called but hung up
after one ring so that's that's fine
with me I want a code
okay let's where's my timer okay let's
set that timer again and now let's let's
just start copying some things over I
think let's see so you know what this
repeater and right now
I'm trying to find what the outermost
element is here okay so
all right let's check on yeah let's
check some of these so it's inspected I
just want to see the structure of it
okay so here's that mega menu div inside
there that's where we have to you ELLs
that are coming and now so let's check
that so here's that mega menu div and
then okay there's another item template
with another repeater okay
so really
this is going to be kind of like the
bottom most level this this item sounds
late
okay in this repeater we'll need this
repeater as well let's check out Mega
Man you don't see ya I may not need any
of these outer things double check
actually I think we should do that okay
so will once like this okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna move this over to my
other screen so I can see it and look at
the code at the same time so here's what
we'll do so we definitely want we want
all of this but we're just gonna have to
change like these I have to change these
to match what we're doing up here so
that's
[Music]
I could split this let me
let me check out I think this is just
okay so this is a big list these are all
allies okay so we can keep this
structure of allies so there's one one
ul over everything and then
okay so we'll have to keep our URL
because they're not there's not a where
I'm sorry our ul our unordered list this
outermost because that's not being it
put in by this template the first thing
they put in is this Li and that'll be
these allies for us and then right now
it's putting in an a tag and a link but
we don't want that right so let's let's
see what we're doing so what we want we
want the a tag but we don't want it to
be a link so let me just bring this down
here just so that we have a reference so
we'll reference that right here so
here's what we want let's remove this
href
and our class we don't need to bring in
a class dynamically it's only just gonna
have the class collapsible header
and then for the data URL we're just
gonna call that faith section
there we go and then we need the name
and we definitely don't want this image
i was actually i actually already hid
that on the main site because it looks
just so old and terrible i guess we
don't need the span either rid of that
and there we go and that's the name so
that's what we need
awesome so that one's taken care of so
that's that's going to be all of our our
top level headers for our side nav right
and now we need to get to these that are
inside here so for right now in my
markup I actually have multiple
unordered lists but if we can do it
differently I think it would be better
it makes more sense to just have one
unordered list so let's see how how we
can do it so now we have underneath the
allies let's check what we have here so
underneath the Li a a tag we have this
div that's collapsible body so let's
let's just copy that and bring it down
here and instead of
so if it has child taxonomy then we're
gonna say I think this is the point
where we'll want to put the collapsible
[Music]
yeah so instead of this mega menu div
we're gonna put our collapsible body div
right there okay this is collapsible
body
and I'll need to escape these there we
go
just okay so I since I was using double
quotes and then double quotes inside you
have to escape them I'm not really sure
how it works
and with.net if I could have used like
single quotes in here maybe I could've
but I decided just to do it like this
since it's being done down here and I
know it works like that all right so now
we'll have for every it looks like for
every section that actually has links
sub-links it'll add this div that's
collapsible body if it doesn't have sub
links it won't it won't add anything
which for right now everything will have
sub link so we'll just keep going
alright so we have another item template
here that's gonna add okay so here's
here's where we can we can change this a
bit since we want one ul yeah one ul we
can change this up get first submenu
item class
now this is this is kind of confusing
okay so there should be allies within
this I'm not sure where they're coming
in at probably coming in on that that
dot CS file so so let's do this let's
move a ul up here yeah we'll get rid of
this div we'll get rid of this you l
will move it up here and then then it
should put in a lies beneath that
yeah let's double check our markup here
collapse body ul and these are just
allies with a tags in the middle okay
that should work that that's exactly
that's exactly what we want okay so
let's do that
we need this green box menu
I need
all right let's try something out I'm
wondering if we can get rid of just
completely get rid of all of that and
just and yeah I think we can so we'll
leave this for Peter here but then for
this we can just get rid of a whole
thing and we can get rid of
is that it no that's not it this was a
closing tags these closing tags now
we'll put here a ul and I don't think
yeah we just needed you out so we'll
open our ul up here and then we'll close
it here so inside that div
okay now this should just output allies
in this same way we want it to here so
let's say that and what we can do is we
can just check out what gets outputted
here without having to change any of
this yet okay so let me refresh
hopefully no errors will see nice okay
so this is looking looking pretty good
so far so let me bring this over so
y'all can see the structure so this is
what we wanted we wanted these sections
right we have the the UL
okay
awesome
so here we go that we have all these
here the only thing I'm not sure about
is is that that first section did we
have that all we did have that but it
was last oh you know what
that's uh that's this one that we left
in here let me take that out
I was confusing me okay let's give it a
refresh and should be should be alright
now
I just got a slack message from the
project manager so let's see you have to
replace the character with so I have
this file uploader right and if someone
uploads a file with a dot in it with a
period in it other than the file
extension then she gets an error when
she tries to get the file I can't
remember what I replaced it with let's
see so you get an error let me see I
think if you used to take out I thought
if you just took out the dot that it
would work maybe I changed the dot too -
no I didn't
oh I don't know I will
all right I'll get to that I mean
all right so I was okay cool I just want
to check to make sure it wasn't an
emergency otherwise we were gonna be
switching gears a little bit and doing
something else on this stream okay but
not an emergency so let's
sorry it's just just let her know I will
be able to get the file alright so this
is working so now what we want to do is
actually put this inside actually put
this inside here so if you remember we
need to keep this outer UL but then
everything else can go so let's do that
is this the outer one yep okay so here's
our outer UL and let me double check
actually I think I think we're taking
out too many us not we are let me
yeah okay so it's not we want to keep
this ul this Li I'm gonna keep it this
you oh okay so this is that one
so just a bit from this Li up we'll take
that out
okay
this is always tough to do especially
when it when I'm on the like the the
trackpad for a Mac select bodies here
the mouse okay
is this it yep that's it
okay take all that out and replace it
with this and everything should work
save it
refresh
whoa check that out all right awesome
let's make sure all right there's links
look good nah haze all right cool so
we've successfully figured out how
everything is coming into these
templates and we've been able to adapt
it to fit the materialise you know side
nav component and I know I said this for
the last couple of streams but this is
really it feels a comet-like reacts
right we basically just popped in you
know our data there's some weird stuff
going on that's definitely not react
like but we know enough now that I think
we can do this we can build out you know
this homepage so not bad see how much
time I have and go from there all right
about three minutes maybe I'm saying
three minutes I'm not sure how much I
get done we do need a logo actually let
me okay
want to double check and make sure that
that still works yep that works too
awesome if you do need a logo to go
there hmm
it's probably gonna take me three
minutes to find that logo
so that's probably not gonna work out so
I think what I'll do is I'm just going
to start the question answer session a
few minutes early and yeah that's good I
this was not bad you know on a Friday I
got everything done I got it done sooner
than I thought I would it works so this
may be my most successful stream ever
but right now I'm gonna scroll up I'm
gonna so if you have a question please
put in the live chat right now if you
don't have a question you'd be great if
you could stick around and help answer
some questions I would certainly value
having your expertise here if you can't
stick around for the question answer
session I totally understand thank you
so much for watching and I'll be back on
Monday probably around sometime around
2:00 p.m. Eastern Time
you can subscribe to the free camps
Channel and you'll get an alert whenever
I schedule the next stream or you could
you could also follow me on Twitter and
I always tweet right after I schedule
stream I put out a tweet and I let you
all know what I'm gonna be doing that
day and when I'm gonna do it and I
provide a link to the live stream okay
okay
okay let's see web some okay so we have
a question rich rich OGG says is
webstorm good I've never used webstorm
so that'll have to be I don't have to be
answered by those in the live chat
because I I just don't know very much at
all about it
Jordan asked why why dotnet it was not
my choice that just happens to be what
this site was built in so I'm not
allowed to completely rebuild the site
from the ground up yet so from now my
job is just to make do with what we have
and make it make it faster and prettier
and hopefully more user friendly as best
I can with with what we have so so
that's why I'm working with dotnet right
now hopefully the next time I work on
this site will be back with react and
that we'll be doing will be doing
everything at that point we'll probably
like back in front end everything to
build this if a question from MH r says
best text editors best text editors for
JavaScript PHP etc I like I like atom
that's like my main editor but I'm using
Visual Studio code right now I also like
that I'm still not really that used to
Visual Studio code so sorry uh-huh kept
feeling that sneeze coming on us hoping
we just go away okay so I'm not that
used to Visual Studio code yet I like it
and I can see a lot of potential in it
I'm not sure it hasn't been out as long
as Adams so I'm not sure like in terms
of the the package ecosystem of you know
it doesn't have as much available for
customization in terms of like packages
already made I don't really know
i-i-i go with those two I've heard
though that sublime is good a lot a lot
of people it seems like a lot of people
that do videos on YouTube use sublime
those are really the only ones that I'm
familiar with
I used to use notepad plus plus back in
the day I don't really recommend it but
it was better than regular notepad
starting out
okay so Shay says hey Jessi what made
you settle on react and material design
for the new university sites and
thoughts of WordPress moving away from
reactants just announced okay so for the
first question for the material design
aspect of it I needed so we don't have
any web designers here at the University
so basically when I was hired we didn't
really have like a standard a fully
developed standard so we had all you
know different sites with you know
really different I don't know they they
just looked they had some elements that
were similar but I mean they they just
looked really weird and they had like
not even that the hex colors weren't
even the same sometimes so it was just
kind of a little bit of a mess so I knew
we needed like we needed something that
could be cohesive right but I I had to
develop these sites mainly that like my
main job was I had to actually build it
you know I had to develop that mostly
front-end but even sometimes back-end
stuff so I knew like I needed to just
settle on a premade system that I knew
worked and I could go with so I liked
material design I thought it was nice it
was simple the docks are very clear and
easy to understand there are also like
frameworks like materialized that were
really easy to use and you know
developed I mean when I first started
using and it was in the early stages so
there were some buggy stuff but I mean
now it's pretty reliable so I just I
chose you know it shows the material
design because you know it seemed to me
like a very simple well known design
that users would be familiar with
already so they wouldn't have to guess
what they're supposed to do or what
different things
and the site you know they I like the
idea that it's so widely used that you
make sure user immediately familiar with
your UI I didn't want people to have to
guess what they're supposed to do so
anyway that's what I went with I'm sure
there there are other things I could
have gone with but I'm not I'm happy
with with going with material design in
terms of react react was the decision to
go with react came later I mean I knew
like everybody kept hearing about react
so I knew like when if when I first
started hearing about it it was this
cool thing but I wasn't sure I mean you
know you know how it is like there's
always new new things coming and going
with JavaScript but it just kept staying
around and getting bigger and bigger and
then I'd hear more about it and then
it'd be like every talk at a conference
was talking about react and you know all
these videos on YouTube we're talking
about react and so then I just I started
I started using I started messing around
with it and I build I build some stuff
with it I built like a site or for a
client with it got familiar with it I
really started to like it and I I like
that there's so many people using it
because there's there's always a lot of
information if I have a problem with
something in react I can usually find
the answer very quickly
I'm not saying reacts the only system
like that but it's it's nice so I mean
there are some other systems that I
could use besides react but they just
don't have that user base so that's kind
of why with react I mean it's not it's
not really like I sat down and really
evaluated all the different systems it
was just kind of going with you know
I've used this a little bit I've used
that a little bit what's really gonna
work for us right now and what's likely
to be to stick around for a while in the
future right I don't want to like with
the site we have right now
we're in a position where the CMS that
we use Ektron their company got bought
out by another company I'm not even sure
you know what the supports like if
there's still updates like it's
basically a dead content management
system right there's not really anybody
that works on it there are very few
companies and developers that work with
that system so you're kind of stuck and
end up having to pay a lot of money for
work that in my opinion from looking at
the work isn't really that great so I
don't want to be in that situation again
so right now trying to find a react
developer is a lot easier than trying to
find let's say like an extra one right
so I don't know I think it sets us up in
a good position to be able to bring
people on either as employees or as like
contract workers that will be familiar
with our system
they'll be familiar with material design
they'll be familiar with react so now
that was what kind of my thoughts just
kind of thinking ahead as to you know
what's and that's the same way we went
with like WordPress for a lot of
handling a lot of our data as a content
management system we could have gone
with some other stuff we use Drupal for
some other sites that have been built
you know by outside contractors but I
like to stay with WordPress because it
has the largest market share right now
among CMS's at least at least last time
I checked I think it had the largest
market share so once again if I needed
to hire somebody to work on that my odds
of finding a wordpress developer are
greater than finding a developer of
probably any other type of CMS right now
so the next part this ended up being a
long answer to the question so I mean
they were there really like three
questions here so the third question
thoughts of moving WordPress away of
WordPress moving away from react that's
the first I heard of it I haven't seen
anything about it so I have I guess I
don't have any thoughts because I don't
have any details right now my first
reaction was is this about the react
license I don't know I mean I but I have
no idea I'll have to
I'll have to find out more about it but
I'm really interested to see what their
reasoning is though if it's just about
the licensing I'm not that worried about
it because I mean I'm a little guy I'm
not I'm not gonna be on anybody's radar
with anything I'm doing I'm just I'm not
worried about that but I could see why
WordPress might be worried about that
jonbi says my favorite text editor is a
stone tablet and a chisel that's
old-school I had a meeting one time when
I was doing some like subcontracting
work for a media marketing company and
we had a Skype meeting with everybody
that worked for this place were all like
remote workers so we had a Skype meeting
try to get everybody together to talk to
each other because we had never met met
before there were people working that
with this company that I had never met
in my life and they they heard me they
liked they heard the sound of my pen
writing on a paper and they were all
like what are you doing you seriously
use paper they were all shocked that I
still used paper especially in a Skype
meeting so sometimes it's nice I've
never gone so old old school to use you
know a chisel but I I can understand
wanting to you know physically you know
leave some marks on something
let's see Rishabh says what is html5
boilerplate
actually I'm thinking so John Hutten in
John Hanson says a boiler plate is a
node NPM install environment many out
there maybe you mean a keystroke
shortcut for HTML and your editor yeah
I'm not sure I guess maybe I don't know
for sure but I thought html5 boilerplate
was just like a starter like some markup
just to get you started that just has
some of the basic stuff you need I like
something similar to what like now I
don't really know I might have to look
this up now because I maybe I'm
second-guessing what I thought html5
boilerplate was I'll look it up after
this jadyn all right now
Jambi says what resource have you been
using to learn c-sharp slash asp.net
umberto I've been using umberto in the
live stream that's that's my resource so
he's not here right now but he's gonna
he's actually on a flight right now to
Denver so he sent me a message earlier
to let me know he wouldn't be in the
chat so he'll probably hear this later
but that's pretty much it I I've I've
been relying on Umberto's expertise and
your help in the live chat mainly
because I I don't see the benefit of me
learning that much of it right now
because for two reasons one this is
right now is the only site that I'll
ever need to work on in the foreseeable
future that uses dotnet c-sharp the
second reason is we're getting we hired
a new web developer he won't be in my
department he's gonna work in another
department here but his job is gonna be
to handle all like the dotnet c-sharp
stuff so he starts October 2nd that's
just in a couple of weeks so if any if I
need any help with that
I'm supposed to go go to him and I'm
gonna handle you know a lot of the all
the react stuff that we've been doing
like that's gonna be my domain and I'm
gonna be in charge of making sure that
the branding standards on the web like
the style guide is all enforced so this
other guy's gonna handle the C sharp and
dotnet stuff and then he's gonna come to
me when he needs more like front-end
design related stuff so that's how it's
gonna work out so I just don't see the
benefit right now and me spending a lot
of time learning something that I'm not
likely to use so I just kind of want to
learn enough to get by
and get this to a point where it's
better I mean honestly it's not really
gonna be that hard to make it better
than it is right now cuz it's really
slow right now but I want to try to make
it as good as I can without wasting my
time learning something so right now all
of my learning time is going into
learning react so I'm learning Redux
right now and I just started learning
react native like maybe two days ago I
started on the react native part of the
course I'm taking so and that's what
I'll be doing after work today and all
day Saturday and so hopefully I'll have
hopefully I'll have a Redux project
finished and then maybe on Monday I can
show you all it's already in on my
github so like my personal github
account has its like Udacity readable or
something if you want to check it out
the design on it is really crazy in old
school so I think I will show you all
when I'm ready to finished just just for
fun definitely not material design
okay Shree Kampf asks is this the new
project yes it is the new project James
Moore says is learning asp.net MVC
advantageous as a front-end developer it
depends on what you want to do I guess I
usually say when I'm asked about what
what to learn really is it just depends
so if you like working with this stuff
or if you know of a company you really
want to work for that uses it then yeah
it would be advantageous if if you're
talking though more in general what's
that meant Aegis for a front-end
developer
I'd say focus on JavaScript because as a
front-end developer you're pretty much
always going to be using javascript no
matter what else you're using you know
Java scripts everywhere so I mean
obviously HTML and CSS right you have to
know that but those are a little bit
easier to learn enough to be decent with
but I would say if you're not sure
exactly what you want to do but you know
you want to do front-end stick with
JavaScript and then once you start to
get an idea of what you like then you
can choose something else to pick up as
well but I wouldn't if someone just came
up and said hey I want to be a friend of
developer what would I learn I probably
never say dotnet that would not be first
on my list
okay there there's been like a running
discussion about text editors throughout
the live chat and now Lara says surely
vim or Emacs is the best it's always I
feel like we've had this discussion so
many times on the live chat about about
editors I really just need to do a video
about editors and then just refer people
to that but honestly I know I've already
said what editors I use and what I like
I've seen people use them and it looks
really cool so I like them I have no
idea how to use them I've never used X I
tried to use it once and I know
everybody says this and it's a joke but
I honestly did have trouble
exiting them right it looks like so I've
just never really had the time to be
able to try to learn it one day maybe
one day I want to be you know the person
that does a live demo at a conference
using them and looks awesome like but so
I don't disagree that BAM and I think
Emacs is a similar situation and you see
somebody using Emacs you're like wow
Emacs and then so let's see
okay so John B says the WordPress issue
is about the react license yes they
decided to go away from react so as not
to propagate the issues of the patent
issue to anyone who uses Gutenberg the
WordPress tool okay that makes sense
yeah that makes a lot of sense that's
what I figured so basically now that I
know for sure that it was the patent
issue my thoughts on the whole WordPress
moving away from react thing is one I'm
like kind of disappointed because I was
excited about WordPress using react so
much but in terms of the impact this is
gonna have on react in general and on my
use of it is it's not gonna impact my
use of it at all and I don't think it's
gonna have my opinion in my unqualified
opinion but I don't really think it's
gonna have a huge impact on react
I think WordPress using react was a cool
thing and it made WordPress seem like
seemed like it was really moving forward
and changing and kind of I don't I don't
want to say being more relevant cuz
WordPress is already you know it has a
lot of market share but it made me think
that like WordPress was really that kind
of forward thinking and trying to push
things but in terms of react it didn't
make me think very much of anything
about react it was just one more
organization added to the long list of
organizations that are to use it so in
my opinion WordPress saying they're not
using react anymore is kind of lowers my
opinion of WordPress but not of react if
that makes sense
I still like WordPress and I'll still
use WordPress and I totally understand
their reasoning for it and I don't know
if I was in the same position I might do
this do the same thing but I don't think
it's gonna have a that big of an impact
on on react it'll be a much bigger
impact on on WordPress in terms of the
direction that they'll they'll be going
in now I don't know what they're gonna
replace
with but they were really seen like
there one in the direction of at some
point down the road the wordpress api
would be the main way things were done
and a lot of you'll be using a lot of
react interacting with the api instead
of PHP interacting with the database and
using templates like at least that's
that's where i thought it was gonna go
but now i'm not sure i mean they could
just they could start using view right i
mean maybe they could use pre act so i
mean they could switch something else in
there and keep going a new but probably
be the same but anyway i'm gonna stop
talking because I feel like I'm in over
my head and I'm not I'm not qualified a
strong opinion on this
Chasez jonbi yep it makes sense for
their business I just wonder if it will
be a big enough issue to slow Reax
growth or for Facebook to change things
yeah that's my my thoughts on it or no
it's not gonna change anything for react
I think Facebook's so big and they have
so many other things they're doing like
it just it's not it seems like a big
deal to us because we're developers and
like we hear about the stuff every day
but in the grand scheme of things react
is such a it's a small part of what
Facebook's doing you know to the world
right I mean when I talk to people who
aren't developers they have no idea what
react is they've never heard about it in
their lives I mean I can tell them like
hey all these other sites use it and
they know like okay that's cool but they
have no idea they know what Facebook is
and they know a lot of stuff about
Facebook but they have no idea of react
is so so that's that's why I just I
don't think Facebook's gonna really care
enough they're happy to just try to
protect themselves from lawsuits which
is from my understanding that's why the
their license is the way it is okay
Laura says html5 boilerplate is like a
template set up to quickly throw a
website together okay so it's what I
thought it was all right cool so so yeah
so essentially it's it's a more kind of
bare-bones version of what I was trying
to do with this
this fus homepage thing these are
originally based on the starter template
I made I wanted just to have some
bare-bones stuff that somebody let's say
like from another department so maybe
like the new developer that's coming in
if they wanted a starting point to go
with it had a lot of the basic styles
that we use and they could just put
together a site they could just you know
pull this down from github and and
already have a lot of it built out or if
we needed to go with an outside
contractor I could just say hey like
start with this and utilize what we have
and then that way it would hopefully
save us some money
because they wouldn't and sometime we
wouldn't have as much back and forth of
trying to make sure that they fit the
brand standards because they would it
would already be built into this so like
I said html5 boilerplate doesn't go
quite that far it's not as opinionated
on style like CSS and things like that
and you know but it'll just give you
some basic you know like this type of
basic stuff right that you need for
every site so I I don't recall exactly
how much is in there but just helps you
skip some of those really basic things
that there's no reason you need to do
that by hand
okay Lord says reasoning behind react
license makes sense but also raises some
issues patent law is flawed and react
license as a product of trying to
protect against those flaws yeah that's
a good point yeah I mean really if you
think about a patent law was you know it
was all developed way before you know we
had like software like we have today or
the internet or anything so it's it's
definitely it makes sense that patent
laws is not keeping up well with with
the way things are now so it definitely
needs to need some updating no beer says
okay nobody's talking about text editors
here I thought it wasn't sure for a
second either read through that okay
they were they were talking about
notepad plus plus for for editing and it
seems like it can be useful but yeah
like I started out I started out on
notepad just regular notepad and that
wasn't thinking about it now that was
insane trying to build websites with
notepad and then I went to notepad plus
plus and that was that was cool there
were a lot of cool features that I was
just kind of learning and once I
switched though from notepad plus plus
plus to Adam I never wanted to go back
like it was obviously better and things
like Adam are obviously better so I'm
sure there are probably some cool
features with notepad plus plus that I
didn't know about and I never used so
there might be some some up useful
things I'm just missing but it was
Mike's my experience was that I really
liked Adam a lot better Abdul Azeez asks
how many languages needed to learn to be
a back-end developer so I would say it I
mean it kind of depends so I think the
easiest route and this is the route that
I'm kind of taking is learning
JavaScript front-end and back-end will
allow you of I think the fastest route
to full stack front-end and back-end
because you know the syntax is all the
same it's one it's the same language
then you have to learn how to interact
with a database and you just have to
decide I guess you know what kind of
database you want to wear
with sequel no sequel I mean it's so I
mean potentially you could get away with
knowing one language and do that I mean
obviously you're gonna be limited to
just that language but you you could
build you know complete apps and things
just with JavaScript and knowing how to
interact with some sort of database but
it I mean it kind of depends on what you
want to do what you want to work on and
in that case you could go like no beer
just mentioned PHP Ruby ASP and then
database languages he says my sequel
MongoDB right even things like right
like c-sharp Java
I'm sure there's there's other languages
less common that are being used Python
it's another big one I was forgetting so
and there are some industries that use
really like ancient programming
languages as well so there's a lot of
things that you could you could you
could pick from but I mean if you wanted
like my personal advice on it I I think
the fastest route is full stack
javascript is that the best in terms of
like career-wise right now or salary I
don't really know I'd have to you know
see some data about that but but you
can't deny it's easier to learn one
language than to write
hahaha Patrick wrote : WQ it I mentioned
earlier that I couldn't exit them so in
case you're not familiar with them
that's how you exit : w kiss I remember
it now now that you put it up there yet
that's that's what it was
he's been tutor for the win
this lost my place there we go
Blake says we should build react 2.0
actually what are they on with three
aren't they it's just about to release
react 16 or something down there you
never like see the version number it's
always just react but I think it's
sixteen Rijn arrow says I need help
please can some good person help me
understanding big o-notation pretty
please I don't know anything about big
o-notation but free code camp has a
series on their YouTube channel on big
o-notation so check out the playlists on
this channel and if you scroll down I
think it was it's kind of an older
series but if you scroll down you'll see
that there's a us I think it's a whole
series on big o-notation if not a series
there's at least one one video maybe
more so check that out and I think I
watch some of it but I ended up not
getting through it because I thought I
don't really need to know this right now
I should be learning something more
relevant to my work so but definitely
check that out and if it's useful let me
know and then I'll recommend it to other
people as well
smiler says hi where can I deploy my
first dotnet website for studying
purposes and like my portfolio
[Music]
okay so Blake says you could do it on
cloud nine
so it's c9i oh that's a great idea I
wasn't thinking about that Blake but
that's that is probably the easiest way
to just get something up quickly
otherwise I don't know I've actually not
I've never deployed a dotnet website on
my own I've always just worked on ones
that are already deployed so so I'm I
can't really help you that much with it
sorry about that I dunno we have someone
that's normally in the live chat and
they just couldn't make it today so if
you come back for some future live
streams umberto who's in the live chat
and he works with with C sharp and
dotnet so he'd definitely be able to get
you get you on the right track
Ranieri says can you tell me the runtime
for this please could you add the
runtimes
right now what do you mean by runtimes
trying to screw up and see if I missed
something
okay
okay so they were taught there there's a
lot of stuff about big o-notation I'm
not gonna read it all I'll just pick out
some things and then we're pretty much
at the end of the live chat so talking
about Jambi says in response I was
saying I don't know that much about big
o-notation I didn't take the time to
really learn it cuz I didn't think it
would be useful for me at the time but
John B says that Big O is useful it
tells you worst case complexity for an
algorithm gives a good indicator if an
approach to an algorithm is bad or not
for example like doing a for loop in a
for loop that's bad okay that's
interesting I didn't think about that
now that you say that I'm starting to
remember a little bit about what I did
learn about Big O notation so yeah ayat
that could I think at the time I just
thought like wow I'm not really doing
anything where I even need to worry
about stuff like that I was just working
on a lot of small like one-page websites
that use like the only JavaScript it
used was just for like UI interactions
like a side nav and you know or some
type of scroll effect or something like
that so but I could definitely see now
that I'm getting into some more in-depth
things it could be useful maybe I was to
take a look at that video series when I
get a chance
let's see James Moore says I appreciate
your services no beer it says Jessie
thanks for streaming you're welcome
thanks for watching and thanks for
participating in the live chat alright
okay that's it that's the end of the
live end of the live chat so we're gonna
finish up the stream here thank you for
watching everybody
and thanks for all your help and all
your contributions to the live chat is a
good stream today we got done exactly
what we intended to get done and without
too many errors and so there's a good
day great way to end the week so I'm
gonna be busy this weekend
working on some some Redux and learning
about react native so hopefully I have
some cool stuff to share with you on
Monday and I hope you all have a great
weekend hopefully not as busy as mine
but I hope you have a fun weekend or at
least a productive one
and I'll be back on Monday and so have a
great weekend